what about if people are constantly
dealing with brain fog this is something
that a bunch of people that I've worked
with over the years have complained
about that throughout the day their
thoughts always feel a little bit
muddled I get the sense that this will
probably correlate with people who are
also sleeping quite poorly they're also
probably using phones late at night but
what is brain fog have you ever looked
at this clinically oh yeah a ton so so
uh we had a YouTube video about this
that that
went really well so I I think the the
tricky thing about brain fog is
as a clinician like we see it Frontline
and people don't really know what to do
so this is where so it's interesting I'm
I mean I guess at this point I'm an
expert in technology usage but my actual
like historic expertise is an
evidence-based complementary alternative
medicine
and and so what we're really seeing in
brain fog first of all I think we've got
to understand that your brain exists
within a body
so and we're seeing this more with like
gut microbiome research and things like
that but for the longest time at least
in eastern medicine
they didn't separate out mental health
from other forms of things like it's all
one thing right because the brain is
connected to the body
so I think what we we're also seeing a
lot of brain fog is a symptom of long
covid so that further
um
demonstrates the kind of like
immune autoimmune inflammation based
results of brain fog so I I think that
brain fog in my opinion is really
probably some kind of low level
inflammation that is going on so usually
when I'm trying to help people with
brain fog it's kind of weird but it's
not much psychological stuff like I
don't think it's like problems with your
emotions or Psychotherapy it's usually
more physiologic stuff so
anti-inflammatory diet even when it
comes to stuff like sleep I think a lot
of people don't realize that you know
especially if you use like marijuana or
like Edibles or CBD to help you sleep it
affects your REM Cycles it affects your
you know sleep stage architecture and
things like that
so a lot of times people will use things
to fall asleep
but don't really recognize or
acknowledge that the quality of sleep
that they're getting is pretty low
I have a kind of a personal Theory which
I've implemented with a couple of
patients which you know none of this is
medical advice but uh you know I've
tried using and when you talk to
patients you have to consent them
appropriately and stuff right so I'll
teach them which is a headstand which
seems to help with everything else
so even in potentially increasing blood
flow to the brain could help but but I
think really sort of focusing on
anti-inflammatory measures turmeric
things like that can can really help
people with brain fog do you know what's
happening with brain fog what what is it
like what what's going on inside of the
brain so my guess is that there's just
low levels of inflammation and or and
that sort of correlates with immune
activation within the brain and it could
be coming from other places too and the
felt sense of that is slower thoughts
yeah infusion less Clarity less
Precision Etc right so if you look at it
the first thing that we sort of know if
we review our you know neuroanatomy and
stroke architecture is that we know that
certain psychological and physiologic
problems are focal so that's one part of
the brain but with brain fog everything
is messed up a small to medium to even
severe amount so it's a global effect so
what kind of if we're talking about
global effects the sources are probably
going to be stuff like inflammation or
hormones or things like that stuff that
affects all of your brain and so I think
a lot of that stuff also with the covid
it sort of suggests that there's some
kind of
ongoing immune reaction or even
hopefully not damaged which I don't
think we really see with covid in the
brain you can you can get strokes and
stuff but that's more clotting stuff but
you know so I I think it's probably low
level of inflammation is my best guess
one of my friends has just started
working with a new
glucose monitor company and when you get
your always on glucose monitor and you
put it on the back of your arm
it comes with uh I think full muffins so
you get it delivered you get glucose
monitoring with your glucose monitor are
four huge super sugary high calorie
muffins and on one of the days that you
don't have anything to do in the morning
you have to wake up and immediately upon
waking you eat two of these muffins and
you track what's happening are you
watching your your glucose shoot up
through the ceiling but you're not
allowed to train you're not allowed to
eat anything else you can't exercise you
can't do stuff to to try and get that
off and the lesson to learn apparently
from this apart from the fact it's how
does your body respond to glucose how
quickly is it able to clear it whilst
it's not training whilst it doesn't have
other things etc etc is also the felt
sense of this is what tons of sugar in
your bloodstream feels like and then for
lunch you have another muffin so you've
had two for breakfast and then you have
another one for lunch and um again it's
just one of the most interesting things
Beyond this is how my body is able to
metabolize glucose and get it out of a
bloodstream and all this stuff that he
learned one of the other things was he
had a number that he was able to now
attach to his felt sense of what high
blood sugar felt like and everybody
knows if you've had a huge binge one
evening you end up having a ton of
cookies or something else and I can
sometimes feel it in my joints I can
sometimes feel it it's like throbbing my
entire body is throbbing because I'm
just so [__] inflamed and I wouldn't
say that I'm hypersensitive to this but
you know everyone can push it if you get
a bag of Haribo tankfastics in front of
you or something and you go I've just
eaten 100 grams of sugar there that's an
awful lot yeah I think something that
people don't really
appreciate is that we have symbiotic
bacteria
and the bacteria that grow in our gut so
a lot of people will like eat will take
probiotics every day whereas like I
think it's
science without understanding so if we
think about okay what determines the
bacteria in your gut it's what you feed
it so some bacteria are able to digest
complex carbohydrates some bacteria are
able to digest simple carbohydrates the
ones that we've sort of learned are
friendly which trigger less of an immune
response or the bacteria that have been
in our guts for thousands tens of
thousands millions of years and those
are the ones that eat like root
vegetables they help us digest those
things and now what started to happen is
we see all this how does food cause
inflammation like we know that fast food
causes inflammation sugar causes
inflammation it's because when we when
we eat these kinds of foods it selects
for we're fertilizing another kind of
bacteria that normally doesn't belong
there because like Twinkie eating
bacteria did not were not symbiotic so
now our immune system is like hey this
guy this bacteria doesn't belong here
but those are the ones that we keep
feeding
and so a lot of this inflammation that
we're kind of seeing I've seen a lot of
stuff around gluten recently where
there's a guy in Austin actually who
uses the strain of gluten that's like
800 years old doesn't trigger Celiac
problems for people and things like that
no way yeah
and that's cool it's really interesting
right so there's no scientific studies
on it yet but I think we're really
starting to see that a lot of this stuff
like diet and things like that which is
usually how we manage brain fog I myself
had really bad brain fog after covid and
went through this whole ayurvedic
regimen and was back to normal
and so it was it was you know I think
that we really inflammation oriented
we'll get back to talking to Dr Kane one
minute but first I need to tell you
about manscaped if you're a gentleman
who needs to trim his sensitive areas
and you are still using an old face
shaver from five Christmases ago what
are you doing join us here in the modern
world there are purpose-built tools for
the job and the manscape lawnmower 4.0
is the greatest ball and body hair
trimmer ever created it features a
Cutting Edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents a 90 minute battery
which allows you to take a longer shave
or if you're just a particularly hairy
gentleman waterproof technology which
allows you to groom in the shower and an
LED light which illuminates grooming
areas for a closer and more precise trim
or if you just want to do it at night
perhaps it's also got a wireless
charging system to help the battery last
even longer but best of all you can get
20 off everything site-wide from
manscaped and free shipping if you go to
manscaped.com Modern wisdom and use the
code modern wisdom at checkout that's
manscaped.com modern wisdom and modern
wisdom a checkout what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
face